oh can I see what can I say what please
do please do about superheroes
television has finally given us a good
superhero it's daredevil now they've
tried many others and it hasn't worked
why does daredevil work because
daredevil has a great fault he has a
great core wound and we see it at the
beginning he was blinded when he was a
little kid blinded by a chemical spill
now what this means is when he fights
crime he's enormously wounded he can't
see anything so what his superpower is
compensation for that wound just as it
is in any great story how does he
compensate by becoming so able to sense
anything and the and the air moving and
the way he's in the space that he's
become powerful because of his wound
because of his blindness so daredevil
has succeeded as a television superhero
because of that and there'll be more of
them but once again it's about a guy's
personal wound
you